it's your turn Moffat so I had to wait
until the last episode that the man
wrote has aired it did and now it is
Moffitt's term for the same treatment I
gave to Russell T days before top and
bottom 10 episodes written by him so
we're gonna start positive we're gonna
start with the top 10 now let's remind
you of the ground rules here first off I
am only considering episodes that he is
the sole credited writer on I'm not
messing with stuff where he had a
co-writer because I don't want to have
to try and parse out what his
contributions were what the other
writers contributions were not messing
with any of that
so only things that he wrote himself are
up for this also a reminder I count two
parters as a single story and I got to
tell you guys compiling this list was a
reminder to me that I know that his time
as showrunner was not great for the show
overall but the episodes that he was
actually solely responsible for there's
a lot of really good stuff on there and
I had a hard time coming up with this
list I have no doubt yours will be
different from mine but let's get going
anyways with number 10 a good man goes
to war there's a lot to love about this
I love the assembling of the team we get
the intro the first introduction of a
number of great characters we get some
fun callback system characters that
we've already seen I love the emotional
rollercoaster of it of the doctor just
showing up and just owning that place
just Amelia pond get your coat and just
waltzes all over these people
confronting that woman getting right in
her face and telling your good men don't
need rules this is not the day for you
to find out why I have so many and then
to go from this year dr. get'em and just
to have that sync of the baby realizing
that they didn't win but then to have it
pick back up again with the river coming
back at the end I didn't see that
revelation I've heard from other people
that they saw it coming and they called
it props to you I didn't I was surprised
and
and moved and excited by that revelation
and I think the moment itself plays
beautifully the music really underscores
it terrifically I just have a hell of a
lot of fun with this episode number nine
asylum of the Daleks now I know from my
own comments section there are some
people who really don't like this
episode I'm sorry guys I think this is a
lot of fun there's a lot I like about
this including the thing that everybody
complains about which is Amy and Rory
having broken up since the last episode
and then reconciling in this episode I
actually think it's really necessary
because the damage that losing a child
tends to do to relationships is often
irreparable the vast majority of couples
who lose a young child don't stay
together and I feel like having them
break up acknowledges the reality of
that and the damage that that does to
their link in their connection but also
by having it happen basically between
the previous episode and this one and
having it just get resolved here means
we acknowledge that this happened and
this was part of their grieving process
was that they lashed out at each other
but we're also not gonna have it happen
over the course of the next few episodes
where it's gonna bog the whole thing
down so I like that I love all the
Daleks I just love that I love that you
can sum the premise up as the Daleks
fire the doctor at a planning expect him
to fix it they say that in the episode
itself and I love that there's a lot of
just neat nifty ideas there's a lot of
cool Easter eggs and I know some people
are like they just put the special
weapons Dalek in there as fans or
something well yeah but they also don't
stop the story dead to do it it's there
if you recognize it it's fun for you it
was fun for me I enjoyed this episode a
lot number eight the day of the doctor
there was a time where this was right up
towards the top but the shines kind of
come off it a little bit as I have sort
of spent more time with it this is still
really good though this is a really
wonderful celebration of the doctors
50th I love a good multi doctor story in
the first place I do think this is a
good one I like the way that Tennant and
Smith play off each other because they
get along pretty
which is actually a typical the doctor
tends to get on his own nerves more
often than not when we have these kind
of stories of course you've got the
great wonderful and sadly departed John
Hurt there to offer the grumpy annoyance
now when I did my ranking of doctors I
did put him almost at the bottom he was
second to last but that was just because
you know comparatively he doesn't have
as much to do but if the characters
gotta be there in the way that he is he
was a great get because his presence
does help elevate it I love the
embodiment of the bad wolf entity and
the way that Billy Piper plays that is
phenomenal I love that thing so much and
I like that the episode kind of throws
you for a loop a little bit it can be
frustrating if you came in based off
marketing you we're going to see the
time war and you don't and it's not even
really about taking on the Daleks it
ends up being in the whole middle about
the Zygons except that I actually think
that that plays into everything really
nicely and how dealing with this
situation where it's complete
brinksmanship but finding the other
solution finding the other way reminds
the doctor that he doesn't have to do
the thing that he actually thought he
did there are other ways there are other
ways around it in all the doctor showing
bleed clips of all of them we got our
first look at Capaldi with the eyes and
those attack eyebrows and it's just I
think it is a wonderful celebration of
this show and of this character and I
think it was a fitting episode for the
50th anniversary number 7 world enough
in time and the doctor falls now as I
said I do too partisan one story and as
much as I kind of wish I could have
separated these two they are a
legitimate two-parter the story is not
complete until we get both halves of
this and the reason I say that's
unfortunate is if I could deal with
world enough and time on its own it
would be way higher on this list it
might even have a shot at number one
having to tied to the doctor Falls which
is still very good and may have still
even made the top 10 maybe like around
you know 9 or 10 but having to link them
together I have to split the difference
and this is where it ends up so as a
two-parter the first half is stronger
than the second half but that first half
Wow
just the wonderful creeping nature of
the Cybermen and what I say creeping I
don't mean like generic creepy I mean
just the concept in the way it just
slowly creeps the this this conversion
of these people and the way that it
changes them in their society slowly
dawning on you as the watcher slowly
singing in just how bad this is gonna
get it's amazing and I love mr. raiser
the whole reveal with John Simmons the
master I think is one of the weak links
so the and again it's not bad but I'm
not sure what it actually added a heck
of a lot but Missy is great I love that
even in the doctor falls there are great
moments I love the doctor pleading with
the master and with Missy just be kind I
love that that was sort of define a lot
of the final notes that that Capaldi's
doctor went out on was pleading just be
kind and I love his moments with Bill
after she's been converted in there
having conversations and he has to admit
that he can't save her even though he
said that he could and what he said it
he thought that he could it's wonderful
its melancholy it's tragic it's creepy
this complete story even though it
starts better than it finishes is really
wonderful
number six blink the test episode of
Doctor Who or at least what I consider
it to be the test episode this is the
episode that I recommend to people who
don't know if they'd like this show
maybe aren't into normally this kind of
thing I have them watch this as a test
and I've had that bear out twice so far
including with my partner who watched I
was like okay yeah watch tomorrow I'm
now getting to show her other Doctor Who
episodes which is awesome and wonderful
but it is completely self-contained you
don't need to know anything going into
it but of course even if you do what you
get is awesome and the angels and this
first appearance are terrifying and
they're this is masterfully filmed it's
got a terrific supporting cast which
most of the best Doctor Who episodes
have and not just Sal
spero who's kind of the one that gets
all the nose Billy Shipton I really like
the policeman and it there's a wonderful
again melancholy I'll come back to that
probably in some other ones as well
because I like that as a mood you know
to his death as an old man and you know
watching this play out like just a
straight-up horror movie with the doctor
as a background feature man this is
tight number five the night of the
doctor I don't care if it's a short it
deserves its place on here this thing is
epically awesome this is an amazing
seven minutes of entertainment that even
if you've never seen Paul McGann before
and keep in mind when I first saw this I
hadn't started getting into the audios
so I didn't I only knew him from the
movie so seeing him in this watching him
just own this part and on the screen and
he's he dies trying to save a woman who
who not only doesn't want his help who
hates him and he still dies trying to
save her and his flippant nough swen
dealing with the sisters when they bring
him back and he he's you can see he's
like clinging he's trying to hold on to
when what he does was fun but this war
is happening all around him and he can't
run away from it anymore and there's a
there's a really heaviness to the
acceptance of him saying warrior in
making that choice at the very end this
I I have such a hard time getting over
how amazing this short is number four
the eleventh hour my favorite episode of
Matt Smith's doctor now that might sound
like a backhanded compliment like Oh
first one was the best one was all
downhill from there no he had a lot of
great stories but there's just something
about this first outing there's
something about the way he fits into
Amy's life and the way that she reacts
to him as a result of that that you know
even as a young woman because he left
her as a kid she's kind of already over
him and not nearly as highly Namur she's
kind of ticked at him and I like that
dynamic I liked it right there right off
the bat I love Matt Smith sort of his
brain rushing
scrambling he's trying to get a hold of
his own thought process
I love the bits of humor where he's
trying to find something to eat but
everything he tries just ah fish fingers
and custard of course
and then the buildup we get to the end
he finally sheds the tatters of
Tennant's costume he puts on the bow tie
and he walks through that image hello
I'm the doctor and I remember even the
first time I saw it I actually said out
loud yes you are and I love Matt Smith
in this part he came out swinging this
is a phenomenal introduction to him to
Amy
it's a great jumping-off point if you
don't want to start with Eccleston if
you want to start at a newer place this
is just a wonderful episode number three
silence in the library and the forest of
the Dead my favorite tenant era episode
you might notice a pattern with these
last four so yeah I have so much I love
him this I love Donna she's my favorite
companion I like River and I think she
was wonderfully introduced and her death
at the end of this gained so much more
poignancy
after you know knowing more about her
later but even at that time it was
touching this is one of those with the
phenomenal supporting cast a great
chemistry to this cast with with proper
Dave and other Dave and Miss Evangelista
and everybody feels like they have an
established dynamic they don't feel like
they exist simply mechanically for the
sake of the plot they feel like real
people with real interactions and real
relationships and so many of my favorite
episodes of Doctor Who have that and
this absolutely has that the Vashta
Nerada or creepy it's a great concept I
love the dark saying you're in the
biggest library in history look me up
that was a notion that got overplayed in
later episodes but this was really kind
of the first time he put his foot down
and pulled that card out and it's
awesome and I love it and there's
tragedy to it when Donna did when those
the the simulation of those kids and she
loses that she sells the hell and then
the triumph at the end of saving kind of
saving River Song it's again that
emotional roller coaster
another episode that has that number to
the empty child and the doctor dances my
favorite 9th doctor episode oh boy this
has everything first off the empty child
how reaping
just as an image in just knocking are
you my mummy and then beyond that the
more you learn about it at least for me
it becomes creepier because the idea of
this child with such a simple relatable
understandable motivation to just find
its mother that can and will destroy the
world either because it doesn't
understand the damage that it's doing or
if it does understand it it doesn't care
because it's single-mindedly trying to
find its mother like a child of that age
would it is terrifying to me and then of
course beyond that we have the
introduction of Jack Harkness who just
Swagger's in and brings this whole
swashbuckling element which I think
honestly plays best against Eccleston
who didn't have that going for him
otherwise Rose is really good at this
she's bouncing up great off both
Eccleston and off of Harkness again
there's a really good supporting cast
here but I think ultimately at the end
of this everybody lives I mean again
that's a you know the show later
developed a real aversion to letting
anybody die but just the way Eccleston
screams that out you feel the weight of
all the times that not everyone lived
and his joy that this time it worked and
it is the perfect capper to a nearly
perfect two-parter oh yeah so fans of
this channel probably know what is
coming in at number one my favorites
Peter Capaldi episode Heaven Sent
and no I don't count it as a two-parter
with hell-bent because even though it
ended in a way that had to be picked up
with a later one it still tells a
complete story of him in this case
so trying to get out at the end he gets
out that story is done the fact that
it's seated the next one doesn't make it
a two-part or at least out of my mind
and as a solo piece of work
god I've droned on about this episode
before but it is phenomenal Capaldi by
himself is amazing talking to himself
his the whole going into his own mind
palace with and it even manages to
capture moments of fun even as he's
processing his grief over what happened
to Clara because we get lines like I
can't wait to see how I get out of this
and you can terrific moans like that but
you also you do feel the weight of his
grief following him around the whole way
much in the same way that that creatures
saw him it which is a wonderful creepy
image that this castle that it feels
both confined and labyrinthine at the
same times like he can't get out of this
castle but man this thing is huge
how does he ever get around here and
then I mentioned the emotional roller
coaster there is nothing that I have
seen not just in Doctor Who at all that
tops the emotional roller coaster this
specific episode put me through because
watching him get caught and die and then
seeing the loop start again and then see
you start again and realizing it just
keeps going then he starts assigning up
amounts of time onto this and realizing
that it's just going to keep going and
he's going to keep dying over and over
and over again and the sinking feeling
of that of just realizing oh my god what
is going on how can he possibly get out
of this and think maybe is somebody
gonna rescue him is that what's gonna
happen here and then you noticed that he
gets a little bit farther each time in
that bird story huh and the revelation
of why he's getting further in the story
and what he's doing and that total
sinking to rock bottom rockets just
straight into the sky into utter triumph
when he busts through that thing yeah
all the yes moffat Wow like no bones
about this at all not a single complaint
not a smidge I don't know if I can say
for certain that it is my favorite
Doctor Who episode of all time but it is
definitely the best episode that Moffat
ever wrote at least that's what I think
what do you think whatever your thoughts
are your own top ten your thoughts on
mine whatever they are drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
maybe also do all those things you know
that have to happen the lights the
subscribes Twitter follows podcast
listens patreon support maybe all links
for all that stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]